[Applauso]
[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti Buongiorno ragazzi è
un piacere una nuova essere qui con voi
stamattina
ricordo qualche settimana fa quando
Francesco l'organizzatore mi contattò su
questo argomento di descrivere un po'
l'equilibrio in un ruolo delicato come
il presidente di una squadra di calcio
in quel momento la prima cosa che a cui
pensai mi ricordo l'unico equilibrio che
conoscevo era lo 0 a 0 e non hanno
nient'altro poi pensandoci un po' di più
in qualche minuto Ho iniziato a lavorare
dei concetti che ho sentito molto vicini
a me soprattutto nell'ultima fase della
mia vita la ricerca di un equilibrio tra
essere un buon imprenditore essere un
anche sostenibile un bravo papà e anche
una cerchia era un presidente di una
squadra di calcio è una ricerca che ho
iniziato da un po' e vorrei oggi
condividere con voi dei passaggi di
questo di questa esperienza e spero di
lasciarvi qualcosa e qualche
insegnamento e soprattutto non ripetere
degli errori che ho commesso io
intanto Partiamo dalla domanda delle
domande è veramente un sogno è un bel
job fare il presidente di una scuola di
calcio Immagino che i ragazzi Qui oggi
avranno giocato sicuramente giocano a
Fantacalcio Fantasy League comprano
giocatori e sognano un giorno di avere
una scuola di calcio per farlo in realtà
era il mio sogno lo è di molti di noi
in realtà ha delle peculiarità molto
interessanti e ti fa vivere delle
emozioni molto uniche ma anche a delle
dei cosa sarebbe anche degli aspetti
molto negativi e molto difficili da
gestire proprio in questa attività vedo
come è importantissimo gestire un
equilibrio interno e soprattutto
teneramente gli obiettivi e
i propri valori
intanto Intanto
vorrei condividere condividere alcune
alcuni fattori positivi di essere
presidente proprietario di una scuola di
calcio Intanto il senso di appartenenza
una delle cose principali che mi
appassionati in questi sei anni di
esperienza è il fatto di poter sentirmi
un po' il papà della squadra Quindi
dall'ideazione del progetto quando
acquisire il lite United era 2016 la
squadra era un po' lo sfascio la società
e lo sfascio le faciliti ed erano un po'
lasciati andare e ricostruire tutto
questo soprattutto dare alla città ai
tifosi al Management la possibilità di
sognare ancora di Riconquistare la
Premier League dopo 17 anni Questo è
stato un percorso fantastico ma
soprattutto per me un senso di
appartenenza Come essere una famiglia si
vince si perde insieme si lotta insieme
si crea un rapporto tra presidente
squadra giocatori e chiunque anche con
la città i tifosi stessi un legame
solido unito che va possibilità delle
sconfitte e verso l'obiettivo questo si
è veramente un aspetto molto importante
questo senso di appartenenza che è una
delle cose principali e positive che ho
trovato in questi 6 anni la seconda è
forse una dipendenza Forse è quello che
tiene molti presidenti che conosciamo in
Italia da 20 anni sulla propria sedia è
l'adrenalina penso che non ci sia
un'altra attività al mondo
A livello imprenditoriale anche legata
allo sport che porti questa adrenalina
vince perde ogni settimana è qualcosa di
unico Io ricordo anni fa in una delle
mie attività ho avevo un'agenzia di
diritti televisivi e vendevo compravo
vendevo diritti nello sport i diritti
della Premier League della Formula 1
Serie A ho fatto tantissimi contratti
Accordi ogni settimana avevo questa
adrenalina commerciale di vendere
diritti e potevo guadagnare milioni o
perderne quindi era un'attività che mi
ha preparato un po' dal punto di vista
di cercare un equilibrio di non farmi
prendere da risultati effetti negativi o
troppo positivi e quindi non lasciarmi
andare allo sconforto o all'esaltazione
nel calcio questo è ancora molto più
esponenziale perché siamo più esposti e
giochiamo ogni settimana quindi queste
questo legame con risultato sia a
livello emozionale come primo tifoso che
a livello imprenditoriale come
proprietario del club è complicato da
gestire l'altra cosa positiva è forse
per me personalmente è quella che mi mi
rende più felice è l'impatto sociale che
abbiamo
pensate a Napoli cosa sta succedendo
forse domani vincendo un altro
Campionato dopo oltre 30 anni
la vittoria sportiva entra
nell'immaginario collettivo entra nella
cultura di un paese
definisce I sogni dei bambini e quindi
cambia veramente le nostre vite e noi
abbiamo la possibilità Io ritengo un
generatore di felicità Perché abbiamo la
possibilità di creare dei sogni e
soprattutto desiderarli
la necessità di conquistare questi sogni
attraverso lo sport sono stato fortunato
perché nel 2020 dopo tre anni in
Champions ci siamo riusciti a ottenere
la Premier League non succedeva da 17
anni e nonostante fosse per me è un
progetto imprenditoriale abbiamo
investito Oltre 100 milioni nel mix
United in realtà quel giorno l'unica
cosa che non ho pensato è l'aspetto
economico l'aspetto finanziario la gioia
che ho dato alle persone vedere i loro
occhi felici capire quante persone
migliaia di persone in tutto il mondo
messaggi da ovunque dall'India
dell'America dall'oceania per un
risultato sportivo ti fa capire quanto
veramente puoi offrire attraverso il tuo
lavoro attraverso i risultati
dell'impatto che hai a livello sociale
però ci sono anche
c'è anche l'altro lato della medaglia ci
sono anche caratteristiche negative
comunque difficili da gestire in questa
attività intanto Intanto è un'attività
molto complessa gestire una scuola di
calcio non è come pensate Ok andiamo a
giocare la partita e finisce lì è una
squadra di calcio moderna ha tantissime
attività nel suo interno passiamo dalla
gestione della FB quindi Food and
beverage facciamo ristoranti abbiamo
milioni per ristoranti ospitality
facciamo concerti matrimoni conferenze
abbiamo la parte di analitica
Custom relationship ma anche nella parte
sportiva analisi dei dati scouti
reclutement parte medicina scienza
allenamento Fitness quindi immaginate la
varietà di attività che facciamo in una
scuola di calcio sono tantissime e non
menzionati solo alcune cioè sono cioè
marketing merchandising e-commerce
creazione di contenuti fare documentari
o contenuti ogni giorno social media
quindi livello di complessità estremo
porta anche un'attività molto complicata
che quella della reclutement che è la
parte fondamentale del successo o
dell'insuccesso di un'azienda e anche in
una scuola di calcio
oltre alla complessità del suo business
c'è anche un elemento che le differenzia
la mia attività come presidente rispetto
alla mia attività Come imprenditore al
di fuori del calcio Mentre nelle mie
aziende posso tutti i giorni parlare con
i manager capire avere un termometro
della loro situazione personale O
professionale stimolarli aiutarli nel
raggiungere i loro obiettivi e
supportare la strategia dell'azienda nel
calcio Questo è molto difficile perché
c'è un intermediario che è l'allenatore
che ha la costante relazione con i
giocatori io posso devo equilibrare la
mia relazione con lui e devo stare
attento a quello che dico perché li ho
trovati tutti molto permalosi dall'altra
parte devo anche comunicare con i
giocatori di tanto in tanto ma
pochissime volte magari due tre volte
all'anno Poi dipende Purtroppo quando
Meno male un po' con Quest'anno devo
parlare di più a loro quindi devo
stimolare il livello individuale o a
livello di gruppo ma devo sempre
equilibrare questa relazione perché se
sono se parlo troppo sono invasivo se
parlo troppo poco sono menefreghista
Quindi è una è un'attività qui faccio
molta attenzione per non invadere il
campo alto e soprattutto quello
dell'allenatore del direttore sportivo e
in questa in questa attività un'altra
un'altra peculiarità e Lapse and down
dicevo prima non siamo soggetti a
risultati sportivi ogni settimana quindi
gestire le proprie emozioni è difficile
per il 95 minuti siamo i primi tifosi
per il resto della settimana siamo dei
manager e Però quei 95 minuti hanno un
impatto non solo sulle nostre emozioni
che possono poi conseguire indecisioni
ma anche sulle attività di manageriale
quindi a volte magari ci facciamo
prendere dalle emozioni e decidiamo di
spendere un po' di più di quello che
dobbiamo spendere e quindi il budget e
il bilancio di società come abbiamo
molto spesso non è allineato alla
sostenibilità come dovrebbero essere
un'altra elemento molto difficile a
volte negativo è l'esposizione mediatica
quando ho deciso di fare l'imprenditore
ma e poi mai avrei pensato di poter
diventare tipo una celebrities e essere
giudicato ogni giorno noi oggi non siamo
giudicati solo da dai nostri investitori
dai nostri partner dai nostri giocatori
dai nostri impiegati siamo giudicati da
chiunque da vedete messaggi dove un
giorno e una settimana può essere
idolatrizzato Come si dice posso essere
ringraziato e dalla nostra giornata dopo
una partita può essere possa essere
insultato questo ormai diventa una
normalità e ci siamo abituati a questa
attività di abuso di continuo abuso è
una cosa che bisogna combattere Bisogna
parlare ma anche quando fai
pensi di essere distaccato e fai finta
di niente In realtà sei una persona
umana Quindi hai investito il tuo tempo
a investito ai sacrificato la tua
famiglia per stare con la squadra
investito i tuoi soldi hai fatto
tantissimo e poi chiunque che senza
sapere niente cosa ci sta dietro i
motivi le hai ragione Ti insulta e tu
devi mandare giù quindi questa è
un'altra caratteristica molto negativa
di questo lavoro di questa attività
siamo esposti
dopo aver sentito diciamo questi Plus
queste parole cons è un'attività che
rifarei
bene dal punto di vista imprenditoriale
e come investimento forse non è
l'investimento più interessante ma è
sicuramente un'attività unica ed è molto
emozionante quindi è molto molto
emozionante ci sono investimenti forse
più sicuri Sì ma anche molto meno
eccitanti e io vivo di Challenge Vivono
di emozioni quindi mi piace vivere in
questo in questo contesto in tutto
quello che faccio l'altra domanda è lo
rifarei dopo sei anni questa domanda me
la sono fatta me la faccio
periodicamente ogni due tre mesi non ho
ancora una risposta definitiva proprio
perché ci sono molti aspetti positivi e
molti aspetti negativi però quando ho
pensato a questa domanda ho pensato agli
occhi che avevo all'amore che avevo per
il calcio per lo sport da bambino e con
quegli occhi direi No no vorrei restare
puro vorrei amare lo sport per quello
che è e godermelo Poi però in realtà ho
fatto già questo salto sono già passato
a essere un professionista quindi in
questo momento l'adrenalina come dicevo
prima è l'impatto sociale per me sono il
vero
driver sono veramente quello che mi mi
Motiva ad andare avanti e quindi sì lo
rifarei lo rifarò probabilmente
continuerò all'inizio o farò anche altre
cose
In ogni caso questa questa attività come
vi ho spiegato è soggetta molti input
esterni quindi è molto difficile trovare
L'equilibrio è un'attività
dispendiosa e riceve sollecitazioni
continue tenere L'equilibrio è
complicato e da un po' di tempo che ci
sto provando in realtà nella mia vita
precedente anche Come imprenditore come
giovane imprenditore ho vissuto
all'estremo molto squilibrato ho creato
attività in giro per il mondo da
Shanghai a Tokyo Singapore viaggiando
tutte le settimane in tre continenti
diversi quindi ho avuto la vita molto
squilibrata Però l'avevo condiviso avevo
degli obiettivi Volevo raggiungere degli
obiettivi quindi l'ho fatto
consapevolmente
e quindi questo squilibrio era
consapevolmente accettato da me e
purtroppo ne ho pagato anche le
conseguenze forse a livello privato a
livello di nella mia vita privata
se tornasse indietro cercherei di
trovare più equilibrio oggi ci sto
provando
e vorrei parlarvi di alcune di alcune
attività che ho pensato e ho trovato in
questa ricerca in questo viaggio verso
l'equilibrio intanto bisogna Secondo me
definire le proprie priorità il proprio
scopo di vita le priorità che volete
fare nella vostra vita privata o nel
vostro nei vostri studi nel vostro
business se sono chiari Le probabilità
Potete iniziare a vivere meglio perché
Potete iniziare a dire di no dire di no
è molto difficile io per anni non
riuscivo ho iniziato Forse da meno di un
anno e la mia vita è migliorata
tantissimo Prima facevo tantissimi
Public speaking inutili cioè
parte perché ero educato in parte perché
L'amico mi mi tirava Per introdurmi
un'idea nuova un investimento nuovo e
alla fine di queste attività questi
meeting erano fuori dalle mie priorità
più importanti dai miei obiettivi però
mi consumavano la maggior parte del
tempo e questo era il tempo che
sacrificavo a me stesso alla mia
attività fisica a imparare nuove cose a
esplorare nuove attività a conoscere
nuova gente a fare viaggi a stare con
mio figlio soprattutto e oggi ho
iniziato questo nuovo percorso e dire di
no aiuta tantissimo a stare focalizzati
sulla propria destination e sui propri
obiettivi quindi imparate a dire di no è
fondamentale sembra un po' scortese a
volte ma è un è un passaggio da fare
la seconda
elemento della ricerca dell'equilibrio
Secondo me è
capire il viaggio Quando ha
intraprendete un percorso e avete degli
obiettivi non pensate allo Shortcut alla
scorciatoia perché la scorciatoia è la
fortuna e succede una volta sola in
realtà dovete capire che ci sono
sicuramente dei momenti di difficoltà Ci
sono dei momenti di sconforto Ma dovete
detenevamente l'obiettivo ma non
stressarvi per l'obiettivo dovete
pensare solo oggi alla giornata
continuare a
insistere a lavorare duro e
ricordatevi di mettere tutto nel
contesto soprattutto quando vedete
davanti a voi un monte una montagna
infinita che non sapete come superare in
quel momento di difficoltà dovete capire
il contesto se siete nella foresta Non
vedete mai la foresta quindi dovete
stranirvi trovate il vostro spazio il
vostro tempo andate a divertirvi andate
a camminare meditate pregate Andate a
farvi un rave quello che volete è
ubriacatevi però trovate il modo di
stranieri e guardare il problema durante
un punto di vista
poi ragazzi Se siete leader del vostro
progetto vuol dire che avete delle
qualità per essere responsabili di
questo vostro progetto dovete anche
seguire il vostro istinto a volte
succede che anche a me un recente
passato mi è capitato di credere molto
nel Management delegare tanto e poi
rimanere un po' passivo è sbagliato a
volte quando si sono situazioni e tu hai
la visione devi seguire il tuo istinto e
anche a volte devi scontrarti col tuo
manager dovrei farlo però devi seguire
il tuo istinto il tuo istinto è
fondamentale perché è quello che ti ha
portato lì e se ti dimentichi di quello
Inizia ad avere problemi e non avere più
chiarezza sulla destinazione
sull'obiettivo finale
poi importantissimo anche trovare tempo
per se stessi Il famoso me Time Io sono
abbastanza eclettico su questo ad
esempio passo da passare delle serate
con i partner amici svedesi a Ushuaia a
Ibiza con ragazzi che hanno 20 anni in
meno di me ad andare a camminare da solo
per sei giorni prima volta nella mia
vita che senza telefono per sei giorni
cammino Non faccio altro che camminare
pensare a me e ritrovare il focus sono
andato a mini cammino di Santiago
praticamente in Spagna è stata
un'esperienza molto interessante e mi ha
aiutato a ritrovare il focus proprio in
un momento come dicevo prima dove avevo
non vedevo il contesto e quindi avevo
bisogno di ritrovare serenità interiore
e pace Ed è l'unica volta che lo faccio
nella mia vita ma sono tornato l'idea di
ripeterlo perché è stato veramente molto
molto utile
oltre a se stessi poi però bisogna anche
ricordarsi degli altri un'attività che
personalmente mi sta molto a cuore e mi
aiuta a trovare il bilanciamento del
equilibrio in una soprattutto in una
vita frenetica è quella di ricordarsi
degli altri cioè ricordarsi degli altri
significa non solo fare beneficenza o
attività sociali Io ne ho alcune faccio
parte di della fondazione UEFA e ho
creato Play 4 Change che è attiva in
programmi educativi attraverso lo sport
però anche nel quotidiano in tutti i
giorni si può aiutare gli altri si può
fare qualcosa per gli altri in piccoli
in piccole gesti e queste queste
attività aiutano soprattutto noi stessi
a rimanere
umiliare coerenti perché soprattutto
quando hai successo e o gli altri ti
creano un personaggio è facile crearti
un ego e sbagliare su questa cosa un
altro e ultimo argomento che vorrei
toccare su questo su questo ricerca
dell'equilibrio ricordarsi delle proprie
origini Spesso mi capita di viaggiare
tantissimo e magari sono faccio meeting
a New York a Londra ma poi mi manca
qualcosa e devo tornare a Barbaiana un
paese di 5000 abitanti dove da piccolo
giravo in bicicletta a fare Guardie e
ladri e sono felice lì e vado dal
panettiere vado al bar faccio cose
semplici normali Dove abita ancora mia
madre e mio fratello e porto mio figlio
stiamo felici del paesino perché a volte
le radici aiutano a ritrovare
l'equilibrio Quindi se venite da paesi
della Sicilia della Puglia da altri
paesi ovviamente ricordatevi di chi
siete e i vostri amici lì la vostra
famiglia perché vi aiuterà Sicuramente
nel vostro viaggio a ritrovare a
rifocalizzarvi sulla destination quindi
per concludere
quello che vorrei dirvi è che in realtà
non esiste una vera risposta per cercare
l'equilibrio Ma ognuno di noi deve
trovare il suo equilibrio a volte le cui
due essere squilibrati per un po' e poi
ritrovarlo l'abbiamo visto anche in
altri interventi però il vero la vera
importanza e l'equilibrio di fare questo
viaggio questa ricerca verso
l'equilibrio e poi non dimenticarsi di
divertirsi e continuare a credere ai
propri obiettivi credete in quello e
credete in voi stessi Grazie